today's topic
welcome to phone swap it's a super
awkward dating show
how are you okay so this concept of the
show is like they broke up two people on
a blind date
and they make them go through each
other's phones so this is the original
thing this is what the cut
kind of copied oh good camera diamond
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
hi i'm cameron and i'm a writer no
matter what i do i always got sprinkled
just a little bit of swag on there it's
all in the lip lick
[Music]
i'm gonna need a little moment
okay listen anybody who uses like the
word swag in a sentence unironically
i'm already cringing that's not sexy bro
that whole ass movement that you did
but when was this film to the defense
when was it if it was 2015-16
i get it if it was 2021
i don't know when this is filmed so you
might be on to something what you be
doing i'm a dancer
oh okay so i'm pursuing my career you
know when you say dancing you mean like
ballet
or even yeah so commercial dance okay i
like to listen
to that you mean ballet or
the way he said they said you mean like
ballet or are you a whole
you know what i'm saying and here's the
thing if you say you're a dancer and
your name is diamond
i'm sorry you're server by default this
is kind of how it works
hey what you doing i'm a dancer what's
your name chocolate
i'm a dancer oh okay i'm pursuing my
career
you know when you say dancing you mean
like ballet or even yeah
commercial dance okay you mean like use
a hoe
no okay because you know it should have
been like
stripper he would have been like
yeah hey i'm diamond and i'm a
professional dancer
i just want to just have fun i'm not
looking for anything serious
i'm just meeting new people and that's
it there's no strings attached
no strings
i'm sorry i like how she's talking no
she's talking like she's blind or
something she's out here like
ray charles in this [ __ ] like i i just
want to have a little fun
you know i'm dancer i'm diamond how you
doing
we don't want nothing serious you
already know what time it is okay so
when was your last relationship three
years ago that's so
for me like i'm on this self-love
journey
because i just got a relationship so i'm
just like reading a lot about like
loving yourself that's just sad if you
finish a diatribe and a man
goes word or that's what's up he did not
give a [ __ ] about the last 10 sentence
you just said
that's what's up now the moment of truth
we just let them know they have to trade
phones
this should not be okay like
she said she's a dancer so i want to
find out what kind of
dancing she really does she just really
wants to know she's a hoe and he can
smash this is what's happening right now
okay youth work i got five bucks so she
can twerk
after snooping through their phones
these two will get to decide if they
actually want a second date here we go
let's see what's in his phone his
phone's empty
let me check out his messages oh no
clutch said wait you have an iphone i
think this phone might be new
fax baby no wonder he doesn't have like
that many apps
let me look at his photos 83 pictures
that's it
i have like a thousand thank god i got
the new phone baby oh
he has a dating app i really hope she
don't click on that date now
addie ashley carly all have the same
thing
part eyes this is his pickup line he's
sending hard eyes oh
my gosh is that how you approach women
it wouldn't work on me
it definitely will work on you shorty
facts you can't just say facts about
something you just said
it's like putting a status on facebook
and liking your own [ __ ] facts
that looks dumb as hell fyi guys don't
be sending emojis to ladies that's just
especially not as an open use your words
use your words you're not 15. i want to
see his social media
oh this is cute oh my gosh rest in peace
nipsey
man i think that's thirst trapping we
gotta stop the violence
yes it is yes but i can't wait to see
your phone
because if you got a thousand pictures
i'm gonna come to her defense if you
have a thousand pig and yes it is thirst
trap
it's worse than first trapping yes it is
how are you gonna post rest in peace
to someone who just died yo the overalls
were blue
but you don't get it the overalls were
blue and what was showing
nip nipsey hustle
i refuse no
that's hot on your recipes i'm not even
gonna play with your name like that okay
all right he really did it's intricate
blue
nipples show it and it's a hustle rest
in peace grandma no
no i'm sorry that's a huge l for him
and you know it thirst trapping is one
thing on a resting piece postman
yeah that's bad it's super bad you know
what it'll be like you remember that
girl jenna from the dog video she loves
to
play yeah yeah dmx in the hospital
she'll be like
and she on all fours rest in peace
and then she's shaking where my dog's at
where my dog's at
oh that's a big ass l that's a big word
bigger l that's a big l yeah rest in
peace
bl fire i don't really notice his name
shout out to you baby and uh
i'm sorry that your grandma died uh
rip grandma your grandma you're dead now
it's okay you're dead nothing can hurt
you
you're dead your grandma rip grandma rip
grandma
grandma grandma's dead now with grandma
i refuse today's video is sponsored oh
wait
all right you already know okay we're
ready today's video is sponsored by blue
chew say it with us now blue chip it's
time for you to gain more
confidence and longer lasting
experiences
in the bedroom with bluetooth tablets
okay you deserve better
she deserves harder get it together
bars listen bluechu is a unique online
service
that offers you the same active
ingredients
as a viagra in cialis but in a true
form and at a fraction of the cost and
one of the best parts is that you know
bluetooth it's an online service so you
don't need to go to the doctor and have
an awkward conversation with that person
all you got to do is go to bluetooth.com
you just need to consult with one of
their medical licensed professionals
and once you're approved we just ship it
to your door and we got a special deal
just for you guys
you can try bluetooth for free when you
use promo code abba
all right and all you gotta do is pay
for the five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com using promo code abba and
get your first
month free so big shout out to bluetooth
for sponsoring this video nipsey man
i think that's thirst trapping we gotta
stop the violence
the day that nipsy hustle got killed
facts that is not
stop saying facts no you know what the
fact that he's saying facts it means
that it's
recent which comes back to whatever he
was saying with the swag thing the
spring
it's uh nepsi died so it's recent
you shouldn't be saying swag you
shouldn't be saying
swag and lick lips and all that if it's
close to where nick
it's after when nip nippy died i come
back what i was saying
you shouldn't say swag facts
that is not promoting stopping the
violence it is this
is a first trap it definitely trapped
her because she keeps going back to the
picture
look at that another thirst trap his
body's dope i think he has a nice body
okay okay i can take that but he's
thirsty
thirsty i'm gonna check out his voice
memos
is he drunk
i have a few questions for cameron yeah
here we go there's a whole bunch of
smudges on the screen let me get that
off real quick oh my gosh
i'm ten thousand photos off the rip okay
oh mad selfies
oh my god i'm embarrassed she's killing
it though cute ray
about 20 rows of the same picture like i
don't know that's a little
veiny a little bit bad that's what they
do that's what they do
yep if you don't what i think though
it's like like there's stuff that women
do
that is like very regular for them that
is goofy like this is goofy
it's normal for them yeah it's still
goofy
but i don't think we're comfortable
enough outside but y'all do is hella
goofy
there's two there's two types of women
though there's a woman that gonna take
selfies and the woman that don't
the woman that do selfies take selfies a
bunch of selfies the same position
everything itself
the ones that don't take selfies are
they have a lot of family pictures
and events or places
peasage and all that landscaping i think
we all recognize the difference but
there is something weird and
super goofy about you having to take 30
pictures to get the right one
it is very vain it says i'm trying to
get the perfect photo
oh let me see oh that's vain yeah
that's dude oh let me see oh
no that's from my axe do not
open that whoa what's going on in this
toilet that was a close one
first of all i'm looking at the stains
in the toilet like what's going on
i didn't do that okay
this don't look like ballet dancing
facts you think that to me
i twerk way better than that oh okay
she's looking like a snack right here
a snack a full course of meal what
you're talking about nah nah i'm not a
snack i'm the whole table
i'm the table and the chest i'm the
first lunch and
what you talking about i'm the whole
supermarket what you mean
and the cherry on top let me see what
has social media looking like
professional dancer we still trying to
figure out what kind
is that shade she getting thousands of
likes she's out of here
i'm trying so you called him thirsty
hey just want another one i know you are
but what am i
oh i'm kind of like torn in between with
the whole
social media i put like a lot of effort
into my social media
i don't like girls who need a whole lot
of attention he's so judgy let me see
who's sliding them dms
i see a lot of dudes that emojis anytime
you put more than three emojis it's
getting real
oh he just used my same line and she
fell for it too
that's me being nice i'm about to check
her notes
no
life is too vulnerable to have the wrong
people in your corner
facts i am willing not to care about
what others have going on and what
others have to say i'm focused on myself
my friends and my family i am beautiful
i'm an amazing dancer this is my journal
like this is my self-love journey i hope
he gets it
i like girls who's passionate and who
actually
want to do something in their life yes
he thinks it's cool
that was pretty fun real that was pretty
fun
[Music]
let me just before you even ask me let
me just explain the
memo okay so i'm trying to step out my
comfort zone
and start singing and stuff you feel me
i know it looks crazy you kind of like
what the
i get like that's what i do with my
notes like like i really like reading
your notes though because
i saw that you really are like
passionate about everything that you do
so i honestly gotta salute you for that
one that gave me like more courage
thanks i saw your dating app and um
what's this pickup line you use just
throwing the line out there seeing that
they gonna bite that's how you shoot
your shot that's how i shoot my leg if i
shoot my shot you're gonna know i'm
shooting my shot
because it's shot because it's going in
like if i shoot i like that
i gotta address the other thing in the
room what was up with that twerk video
okay first of all that's just a gif i
use gif
according to the creator it's jif is it
according to the creator
yeah like the peanut butter jeff still
saying gift i'll give
i agree you don't give a [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ]
i don't know like i don't i didn't know
i'm a dancer that's
out better than that so do they want a
second date
i'm pretty sure they do i'm pretty sure
they do no matter how corny we sit we
think it is or whatever what not
whatever
they think at the end of the day it's
that you have a good time
we shouldn't even be we wouldn't be
supposed to watch this you understand
what i'm saying
we shouldn't be even be supposed to
watch this but in closed doors you
saying whatever
the hell you're saying and you're having
all of this flows
do you that's right that's right that's
it that's all that matters it's time to
trade back phones and find out he said
[Music]
i would take her out again and show her
the swag
she said of course i think it's corny
but if she likes it
she likes the swag then if he doesn't
and it's not broken and it works
then it's not stupid it works find yours
boo-boo sometimes things work
despite the fact that you're
self-sabotaged
yes okay you can pick up girls if you're
handsome and you got smelly-ass armpits
and you got b.o you can pick him up
it doesn't mean that having b.o and
smelling like a trash can is a good idea
the same way right there's no reason for
you to raise your armpits and it smells
like
somebody put a little swag in there
right that's nasty facts
okay all right so all i'm saying is you
write
keep doing it but just recognize that's
just cringe
all right that's all i want to say you
said of course with the little hearts
okay that's what's up that's what's up
we should definitely go out you like
sushi actually i
don't fair enough fair enough so you
know no sushi no sushi
definitely don't want the toilet looking
like others
petty i like that i like that i ain't
mad at you they're having fun
that's it you know sometimes like see
people just enjoy themselves
go corny [ __ ] go that's right that's
right that's right
i like that i think it's fun it's a cool
concept it's much more laid-back than
the other ones that we saw like lisa the
cut one which was so ruthless this one
was just fun
yeah and i enjoyed it so yes what did
you guys think
in the comments below do you guys like
to put swag on things you guys think
this video was facts
okay let us know bro and get you twerk
[Music]
how much